j'accueille maintenant mano solo
un seul au bon soir alors vous avez
déclaré à longueur d'onde
j'aime pas la télé mais j'adore y aller
c'est vrai que je peux pas y passer sans
faire le zapping
parce que finalement la télé fait pour
ne rien dire et moi j'ai toujours
quelque chose à dire donc voilà si
combats d'al ahly 20 minutes un titre
elle a aujourd'hui ce que vous avez à
dire mano solo c'est que vous sortez
indices votre huitième album depuis 1993
ça s'appelle les animals alors au départ
la moitié des morceaux étaient destinés
à juliette gréco
mais la sphère ne s'est pas fait et
c'est vous qui les chantent et voilà
alors gréco vous dit quand on vous dit
qu'il ya du sexe et de la sueur dans
votre dans votre album rock qui voulait
ça voilà c'est gréco qui qui trouvait un
peu mignon ce qu'on lui avait fait
jusque jusque là où elles en étaient
rendus dans sa production à la guy roux
maintien welch et moi 10 10 en 10 sec
c'est bien sûr rappelons que la belle
juliette qui dominait sacha distel way
absolument absolument
on s'est rendu compte ce soir faut vous
le dire quand même que sacha distel en
fait étaient dominés nous le prenais
pour un un playboy il voir rigole pas
sain peut pas du tout en fait que ça
soit juliette gréco jeanne moreau ou
brigitte bardot elle le dominer et elles
ont planté et il était très malheureux
en fait sacha distel et est un
sentimental voilà ce qu'on a appris ce
soir
malheureux malheureux avec les femmes
sacha distel ma chanteur malheureux
chanteur malheureux voilà alors à part
ça votre album est un album assez
apaisés inclure les moins qu'avant non
bah c'est parce que c'était pour
juliette avoit la bresse et les chansons
qui sont dans une tonalité que j'avais
fait pour elle quand même je vais bien
travailler quand même pour sa grosse
voix chaude et pas vraiment la mienne
donc là je suis obligé de le chanter
comme j'ai pas dit ça me fait bien
rigoler parce que j'en ai marre de ne
pas écouter mes disques en fait parce
qu'il soit le motif
il ya aussi une chose c'est peut-être
que vous êtes devenu plus sociable en
français sur dix dans le présent bien
sûr évidemment il faut être con quand
même con côté que des bons retours quoi
il reste est aigri il faut avoir moins
de coups c'est quoi qui vous a appris à
vivre la réussite en fin de le contact
avec les gens de la reconnaissance avec
le public oui mais que la salle soit
pleine en fait c'est ça qui est
important les dix qui sont là pour ça
ce qui est important c'est que pendant
deux heures vraiment je m'éclate comme
un ouais comme en gardent un coeur quand
même pleine liberté
c'est à ça c'est précieux il ya un
morceau qui s'appelle savane où vous
dites je n'ai plus ce sentiment si
violente si méchant non c'est vrai que
au début je montais sur scène j'en avais
absolument rien à [ __ ] de ce qu'on
pourrait penser de moi quoi ça que
j'avais juste une envie c'était de
mettre dans mes chansons dans la gueule
des gens en vérité c'était un peu
effectivement en cours de route
mon plaisir de monter sur scène il a
complètement évolué là c'est moi j'ai un
plaisir de monter sur scène parce que je
vais me fendre la gueule avec des gens
qui il a quatre ans que ça de moi c'est
complètement différent
c'est plus du tout envie de leur faire
du mal alors il ya un morceau vous êtes
à quai à la trinité travail famille
sarkozy
ouais ça vous inquiète sarkozy vous
pensez que quand même j'ai pas j'arrête
pas de penser à tous ces gens avant les
élections qui qui qui était persuadé que
la droite et la gauche c'était la même
chose
depuis quand même quelques temps que
franchement c'est pas la même chose
quand on voit des gens qui déboule au
pouvoir et qui savent et qui s'attaque à
qui ose gitans ils ont stigmatisé les
gitans il y avait même eu des députés
pour lire oui on se demande bien comment
ils se payent leur bagnole je trouve
qu'ils ont fait que ce à quoi d'essayer
de retrouver des têtes de turc
comment ils ont fait avec les
intermittents aussi c'est à dire que
nous les intermittents génère de
l'emploi bien plus con et parasites
comment comme celle d'hier a voulu le
faire croire
sur s'aggrave quand même qu'on ait un
sarkozy avec lui et puis un sarkozy au
medef ça fait quand même un bon je suis
pas moi un type engagé simplement quand
on a la chance comme moi d'être artiste
de rien [ __ ] de ces journées on peut
pas ne pas assister à ça et avoir envie
de le dire quoi une manière ou d'une
autre qu'il serait peut-être temps que
que bacon qu'on se réveille qu'on arrête
de deux moutonné quoi c'est maintenant
c'est encore une fois une chanson à mi
figue mi raisin parce que je dis que je
me fais mon petit grand soir pousser le
ridicule pas je suis un seul à des grès
sur ma chanson avec laquelle je n'en
dormais quand j'étais gamin quand le
chant des partisans
c'est un peu pathétique de la chanson
s'appelle du vent
partisan
de là
g
alors vous n'êtes pas très nouvelle
chanson française
pour benjamin biolay et bénabar yann
tiersen c'est pas trop votre on les
entend passer de jeu c'est le mec qui
susurre pour les vieilles des histoires
de complètement consensuelle et qui
mange pas de pain des petites
historiettes je sais pas moi je n'entend
même pas j'écoute même pas quoi c'est
plutôt quoi elle était très de ouais
c'est ça c'est les têtes j'aime bien
c'est quelqu'un que je respecte parce
qu'il ya autre chose que des chansons
niaises pas cessé c'est tout un univers
culturel cliquez sur scène passé mano
solo libération de 24 septembre
chroniques et les animals sous la plume
de ludovic perrin en dix ans mano solo a
tellement annoncé sa mort que sa survie
a aujourd'hui quelque chose de banal
réchappé in extremis à grâce à la
trithérapie
le chanteur du sida a progressivement
ouvert son propos au monde contre lyon
mais elle ses souliers banques du pool
oeuvre pour ça je veux mon étoile comme
ça tout le monde est content finalement
c'est ce que veut on peut pas vivre dans
ce pays en ayant dit une fois dans ta
vie que tu était atteint d'une maladie
sans contre la ressortent à chaque fois
que tu sais pas qui sort quelque part un
flux qui membres je suis éclaboussé
partout où je passe quoi j'en ai un peu
plein de cucquois maintenant je vais
peut-être réagir à la limite qui tout on
va croire que je tiens ça y est on a
pris toi aussi
ça en fait ce qui émane une seule hausse
qui t'énerve sais que tu n'en parlait
plus et d'un seul coup libération plutôt
des gens qui rédige en tournée c'était
parler pour moi parce que j'ai bien joué
alors oui toi ou doctor il est là depuis
dix ans poursuit
j'en ai plein cur dire que plutôt que de
dire que ton disent que leur plaisait
pas il a fallu que quand un conte
introduisent l'article par le fait que
moi je suis champion du cisa je sais pas
où ils avis à sétif
mais cette séparation si tu veux il est
0 à l'aller perrin j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
de lui céder pour moi c'est l'exemple
type de toute la presse entière depuis
dix ans qui me poursuit finalement je
suis une démonstration permanente que il
règne dans ce pays une exclusion
positive si tu veux par exemple j'étais
le titre de
de mon article de mon droit de réponse
dans libération aujourd'hui ils n'ont
passé en droit de réponse en enlevant
tout ce qu'ils ont merdé bien sujet et
ils ont rajouté le sida dans le titre
moi m'ont dit il c'était d'exclusion
positif le dire le titre est devenu un
sida comme excuse on veut positif
ça veut plus rien dire ce que je dis
c'est comme le belge de ramener le cid
est exactement la fois senna tout le
monde le sache quoi ça
donc sachez le voilà je j'ai trouvé un
truc je moi je met mon étoile quoi comme
juif
sachez le quoi ok que tout le monde
sache quoi ça bien foutu l'ambiance ça
saoule enveloppe non mais c'est vrai que
tout le monde le sache lorsque tu dis
toi c'est que tu es artiste avant d'être
sidéens et chaque fois entre sort ça
quoi voilà les libère exactement c'est
comme si ton belgrade par exemple je
fais des chansons pour juliette gréco
jeu jolie dans une dépêche de l'agencé
de presse que animaux dans une chanson
qui s'appelle je n'y peux rien je parle
de ma séropositivité doit jeûner c'est
n'importe quoi ça devient c'est de toute
façon une information qu'il est
indispensable de donner dès qu'on parle
de mano solo
donc moi je commence à en avoir plein
qui j'ai cru que cette démonstration
était flagrante et qu'elle finirait par
être comprise de tous mais finalement
non elle n'est pas flagrante c'est pour
ça que je te monty cinéma aujourd'hui
c'est parce que j'en ai plein qu
aujourd'hui parce que ça commence à bien
faire moi je vis et finalement ce qui
est paradoxal finalement c'est que quand
ils m'ont cru le porte drapeau d'une
maladie j'étais pas malade aujourd'hui
je suis malade j'ai vraiment autre chose
à penser autre chose à raconter autre
chose à est né mon avis et provoque
cherchiez que leurs conneries moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on lâche la grappe
en fait on a parlé dans ton premier
album en 93 ça fait quand même longtemps
tu disais j'ai la mort aux trousses qui
me fout les x et en 95 ch en a parlé une
deuxième fois sur la scène du bataclan
en disant cette phrase fameuse de
nouvelles une bonne et une mauvaise
la bonne c'est qu'il pût séropositives
et le sida j'ai droit d'en parler
ouais
aussi le droit d'être tranquille j'ai le
droit de ne pas être montré du doigt le
droit de pas sa figure pas sur mon front
sur la carte d'identité tu vois je crois
j'ai le droit de deux qu'on fasse
attention à ce que mes chansons bordel
de merde tu vois qu'une critique le type
il a trouvé que mon album n'était pas
terrible il a quel dire je n'en ai rien
à [ __ ]
teva est pourquoi il a besoin de dire
que c'est vachement moins bien dans ses
livres ce qui était facile et tu va
mieux
voilà c'est ça plus se sentir les
monumentales ça sert en fait ça va faire
encore penser aux gens que grâce aux
trithérapies on ne meurt pas des
finances et ce qui est une connerie
monumentale
alors aujourd'hui alors que les
charlatans et des capotes parce qu'ils
s'imaginent contre un sort commun avec 3
aspirine voix c'est à tous les niveaux
c'est nous importe c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi quoi et par exemple il ya
aussi c'est intéressant quand on voit
que dans mon droit de réponse je parlais
d'un article moi j'avais parlé
effectivement du sida pendant les bons
coups de la paix etc a survolé paris
reste en lice avec placé pour de
poussière voulez parler du sida qu'on
aille voir les docteur tu vois que l'on
a quelque chose à raconter
mais moi j'ai rien à dire tout va et
cité un article que j'avais cité dans
mon droit de réponse pour dire ça ils
ont enlevé ce bout d'un coup je parle de
ça et perrin refait un droit de réponse
au droit la promotion en disant tu vois
dans cet article on a parlé c'est
carrément une manipulation mais c'est
démentiel tu vois c'est à dire il faut
absolument en plus qui c'est le dernier
mot tu vois c'est quelque chose de chez
pas pour moi c'est s'aider lepénisme ça
va pas chercher plus loin quoi c'est
stigmatiser en permanence un individu
moi je ne supporte pas parce que je
pense que j'ai connu autre chose avant
que cette cause un discret depuis dix
ans je raconte autre chose de gens sinon
il faudrait pouvoir franchement je ferai
de cons pour acheter les dix d'un mec
qui parle de 6 à depuis dix ans en plus
ils crèvent pas alors qu'il s'est
infléchie et quoi toi c'est un peu ça ne
pas crever quoi toi si tu revenais james
dean mais c'est bien fait les choses au
point là ouais j'en profite des
trafiquants les regards des mecs
là
alors